- Democrats are in
messaging mode right now.
So they're going to
fight Republicans
in the House on
everything we do,
because in the House
is the only place
that Republicans
have national power.
We don't have it in the Senate.
We don't have it
in the White House.
So they're in 2024
presidential campaign mode.
So Hakeem Jeffries, the minority
leader with the Democrats,
he calls us extreme MAGA
Republicans every single day.
AOC calls us fascist
and every other name
that she can think of.
Although I would say
people should really
pay attention to AOC.
She's the true fascist.
You see, what fascism is,
is it's that, I call
it the unholy union
of big corporations
and big government,
and they have completely
aligned together,
and it hurts the little people,
the little people that she
claims to protect and support.
(cerebral music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the Congresswoman
representing Georgia's
14th District,
Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Greene.
Welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you, it's
good to be here.
- I am glad to have you.
I said to you right
before we started,
we've got some poles up here
that I thought maybe you
could do some pull-ups from,
because you're always doing
exercise on the Capitol.
Should we start that way
with a couple pull-ups?
Or maybe we'll finish that way.
- We can finish
that way. (laughs)
- We'll finish that way.
So, you know, it's funny,
I've never sat down
with you before,
and I'm sitting
down with probably
about 15 or 20 Congress people
and senators, et cetera,
and people think of you
as very controversial.
And so I was like, all right,
I really want to figure out
what is truly like
the position you hold
that is the most controversial.
And I really couldn't
come up with that much.
So maybe we start there.
What do you make of
that notion in general?
- Well, it seems to
be in Washington DC,
if you come in very
convicted in your beliefs
and really represent
your district
and the beliefs that
your district hold,
you know, things like secure
borders, a strong economy,
freedom of speech, protecting
our Second Amendment,
say no more foreign wars,
let's focus on America
and America first,
being unapologetic
about being pro-life,
wanting to protect children
that seem to be under attack
from these gender
lies, things like that,
Washington DC and the
mainstream media labels extreme,
but actually in real America,
you know, Northwest Georgia,
where I come from, and pretty
much all across the country,
those types of things
are not extreme.
It's more Washington DC's
position that is extreme.
- Do you sense that maybe
some of that is shifting?
I sat down yesterday with
Speaker McCarthy at the Capitol,
and he was talking
about the agenda
and sort of the new
Republicans that are here,
and there does seem to be a
better messaging at the moment.
It's partly why I'm
here for three days
to talk to all of you guys,
because it does seem
like something's a
little bit different
than say the Republican
of 5 or 10 years ago.
- Yes, and I think I can say
I've played a role in that.
That was one of my objectives
when I came to Washington,
was to change the
Republican party.
You see, I was a
regular American, never
had run for office,
wasn't involved in
politics at all,
but I was very upset with
the Republican party.
I was a Republican voter,
but I didn't feel
like the Republicans
in Washington
reflected our values.
And so, since I've
come to Washington,
I've never backed down on the
messaging that I've brought,
the bills that I've introduced,
but also having communication
within our conference.
Sometimes it's been arguments,
you know, it's
been confrontation.
At times, it's been explanations
and really good
conversations of,
here's where our Republican
party needs to move to.
This will reflect our
voters across the country
and then really be good
for our country overall.
I supported Kevin McCarthy
in the Speaker's race
because I spent a lot of time
talking with him ahead of time
about what his goals were,
what his objectives were,
and also I developed a
relationship with him
and was really glad
that he listened to me
and the things that
were important for
my district as well.
- Was it funny how that
whole thing was working out
in the strange
bedfellows that created,
because it was like
Trump was supporting him,
you were supporting him,
Gates, who obviously you're in
line with on a lot of things,
was not supporting him.
And then everybody was sort of,
the media was loving the fact
that you guys weren't
all walking in lockstep,
which actually I
tend to think is good
that people are
thinking for themselves,
but that it created all
of these odd relationships
that maybe didn't exist before.
- Well, I think, what it did
is it pulled back the curtain
into the Republican conference,
and it showed different views
that the media didn't expect
and a lot of people, of course,
just watching from the
outside didn't expect.
Over half of the Freedom Caucus,
I'm a member of
the Freedom Caucus,
Over half of the Freedom Caucus
supported Kevin McCarthy,
myself, Jim Jordan, many others.
But then some of
my best friends,
the people that I'm
always in line with,
they didn't, they opposed him.
And then you saw the
debate back and forth,
sort of the internal war.
But like I said, it
was all on display
on cameras, on C-SPAN,
and the media was front and
center, of course, enjoying it.
Well, you wanna know why.
The media really likes
to see Republicans
fight with each other?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But I have been calling
basic, our internal arguments,
I call 'em the civil
war within the party.
And I think it's
good, I really do.
This is what
Washington is about.
It's a place where we
hammer out debates,
we discuss policy, and, yeah,
that means that we
argue sometimes.
I never think
that's a bad thing.
What we do have to do in
our conference though,
is we worked it out, we elected
Kevin McCarthy as Speaker,
we had our rules packaged.
It was the same, literally
the same from day one
to the last day,
only one change,
to motion to vacate the chair
went from five
members to one member.
That was the only change
in the rules package.
But what we had to do is
we had to say, all right,
now that we've been through
this, we have to come together.
'Cause there's only
222 Republicans,
takes 218 to pass anything
on the House floor.
And we have big battles ahead.
We have the budget, we've
got the debt ceiling fight,
where we are gonna
have the NDAA.
We've got big things
that we have to do.
We don't control the Senate,
and we don't control
the White House.
So it's some challenges ahead.
- So speaking of those
numbers in the Senate,
one of the things that
you guys just did pass
is this parental rights
and education bill.
And as a Floridian,
I am well aware
of a little transparency
in education, obviously.
Were you shocked that not one
Democrat signed this thing?
I mean, all it is
about is basically
that you gotta sign up.
Like back in the day, third
grade, you're going to the zoo.
Your parent has
to sign something
saying you're going to the zoo.
I mean, it really, it's
just about transparency.
- Yeah, no, they fought
us big time on it.
When you're a father as well.
So I'm sure you appreciate it.
And being from Florida,
you love your freedom.
- [Dave] We do love our freedom.
- No, we fought the
Democrats on it.
And so the the things that
they said in the bill debate,
I actually presided in
the chair in some of it,
and then was paying close
attention to that committee.
They were accusing
Republicans of banning books,
book burnings and
not teaching history.
They even called us racists.
They called us all
kinds of names,
when what we were really
saying is we want parents
to have the rights to have
control over curriculum,
to be able to talk to
their school boards,
of course, have control
over their children
'cause they're the parents.
And then the second piece there,
they're also the taxpayers
that fund the schools.
So I think their voice
should be just as important.
And all of us Republicans agreed
in spite of not one Democrat.
- So when AOC basically
calls this thing fascist,
which she did on the floor,
and then, was it Hakeem
Jeffries, I think said
that they're not gonna
teach, they don't want,
the Republicans don't want
the Holocaust to be taught.
I'm guessing these guys don't
talk to you on the DL, right?
Like you're not
getting a lot of hellos
in the hallways
there and being like,
"Hey, guys, you
know, it's not true."
- No, no, and, well, here's
the mode that they're in.
So for people to understand,
Democrats are in
messaging mode right now.
So they're going to
fight Republicans
in the House on everything we do
because in the House
is the only place
that Republicans
have national power.
We don't have it in the Senate.
We don't have it
in the White House.
So they're in 2024
presidential campaign mode.
So Hakeem Jeffries, the minority
leader with the Democrats,
he calls us extreme MAGA
Republicans every single day.
AOC calls us fascist
and every other name
that she can think of.
Although I would say
people should really
pay attention to AOC.
She's the true fascist.
You see what fascism is,
is it's that, I call
it the unholy union
of big corporations
and big government,
and they have completely
aligned together
and it hurts the little people,
the little people that she
claims to protect and support.
Yeah, AOC's really the
fascist herself, and Hakeem-
- Isn't it funny that, I mean,
that's right outta
rules for radicals,
that you're supposed
to accuse the others
of what you are doing.
- That's right, and they
do it, and they do it well.
Joe Biden's doing
it right now too.
If people have been
paying attention,
he's tweeted out in the
past like week or so.
He's blaming Republicans
for not wanting to
fund border security
to stop fentanyl from
coming in the country,
which is laughable,
because under Joe Biden,
we've seen fentanyl increase.
It's literally doubled
coming in the country.
And over 300 Americans
die every single day
from fentanyl poisoning.
So they are in messaging mode
accusing us of what they
literally do and lying about it.
- What's going on in
Georgia these days?
Because it seems like
it's hard to understand
fully what's happening
with Georgia.
There are Senate seats
that kind of seem like
they could go either way.
They end up going blue usually.
Obviously, Kemp did
better than, I think,
better than people anticipated.
But it certainly could
have gone the other way.
And you have an election
denier running against him,
even though it's supposed
to be only Republicans
that are election denier.
It's sort of a weird state
in terms of making sense
of what's going on there.
What is that?
- Yeah.
It's probably hard for a lot
of people outside of Georgia
to understand exactly
what you explained.
So Brian Kemp, our governor,
did something really well.
When all the covid
shutdowns happened,
Georgia, and, sorry, Florida,
we were actually the first
state to reopen, thankfully.
And that was something
I had talked with
Brian Kemp a lot about.
I would call him, "Governor,
we've gotta reopen.
We need our schools reopened.
Our businesses need
to be reopened."
You know, basically begging him.
Thankfully Governor Kemp
listened to all of us
that were asking him
for these things.
We reopened, so our
businesses got open again.
People went back to work.
Our kids weren't trapped at home
suffering from, oh my gosh,
the list goes on with that.
But so people in Georgia
had a lot of things
to be happy with
Governor Kemp about.
Another thing that he did is
he passed constitutional carry.
The Georgia is a big gun state.
We have a lot of gun owners and
Second Amendment supporters.
So that was a critical
piece of legislation
that he got done.
And we have a very strong
economy in Georgia.
So these are the things that
people may forget about,
where they get caught
up in watching like,
the President Trump,
Governor Kemp arguments.
You know, those,
then those are really
more side stories instead-
- Because Trump did want
him to keep the stay closed
longer than he did.
- In the beginning, yeah.
That's what Dr. Fauci, Burkes,
they were advising
President Trump.
You can't fault President Trump.
He was listening to the people
that were supposed
to be the experts,
and, yeah, he was telling
everybody to shut down.
Brian Kemp reopened.
And I think there was a list
of others that reopened.
So that shows you like
some of the reasons
kind of behind the scenes
why people in Georgia
supported him so much
in his reelection.
- So why do you think the
Senate seats go the other way?
- Well, I think it had
to do with candidates.
I think it had to
do with campaigns.
Another thing that
people may not realize
is a campaign is
just like a business,
and not all of
them do a good job.
They really don't.
There's a lot that
goes into a campaign.
Its messaging is
really important.
There's TV ads and placement,
radio ads and placement.
Social media is even just as
important as TV and radio,
maybe even more so.
It's your ground team,
door knocking, phone calls.
I mean, it literally
is a mini business.
And they don't
always do it well.
Herschel Walker's campaign
was run by Washington DC,
wasn't run by people in Georgia
that really understand
Republican Georgia voters.
Mitch McConnell's
views and values
are not accepted in Georgia.
And that proved to be true
with Kelly Loeffler's campaign.
So when you have
team Mitch shirts
going around in my
district, knocking doors,
that's not a good look
for your Republican
senator's candidate.
And that's just the truth.
- Let me ask you a
couple of other things
that you're sort of in
the middle of right now.
You were banned on Twitter.
Was that your personal account
or your government account?
- Just yesterday, it was
my government account.
- Oh, you were banned
yesterday again?
- Well, okay.
- I was talking about,
I didn't even know that.
I was talking about
the original one.
- Okay, so the original one
was my personal and
campaign account,
banned for the
entire year of 2022.
It was during my reelection.
I couldn't raise money,
I couldn't message. I
couldn't put my ads.
I couldn't fight back
and defend myself.
I only had my
Congressional account,
but I got it back when Alon
Musk bought Twitter, thankfully.
Now yesterday, my Congressional
account got banned,
and they said it
would be seven days.
Do you know what I shared?
- [Dave] What was it?
- I shared the same thing
that many media companies,
Daily Caller and others
were writing articles about.
It was about the
Trans Day of Vengeance
that was being
planned, is planned.
- Oh, I did see the tweet.
I didn't realize you
were banned for it too.
I know that Sean Davis.
- Whole bunch of people
got banned or got striked
or locked out of their accounts
because we were warning,
this looks like a violent
extremist terrorist.
Antifa, I have
entered a resolution
to declare them as
domestic terrorist.
That's what they are.
The group organizing it is
an Antifa group locally,
and they're
organizing this event
called Trans Day of Vengeance,
just on the heels
of the horrific school
shooting in Nashville.
So all of us were in alarm,
and I tweeted about it and
got banned for seven days.
But they've reopened my
account this morning.
- Oh, so did they force
you to delete the tweet?
- Of course, yeah.
- So they forced you
to delete the tweet,
but they did at least
let you back up.
- Yeah, but they
were whitewashing it.
Look at this,
they were trying to completely
take this off of Twitter,
which is wrong.
And it was, this wasn't
any of us attack.
It was not an attack
on LGBTQ, not at all.
This isn't an attack
on anyone's identity
or sexual identity.
We're literally warning
about a violent event,
that sounds violent
and seems connected to
the Nashville shooting
right there in
the Supreme Court.
- I'm pretty sure if they had
the MAGA Day of Vengeance,
people would not be that
thrilled about that.
- The DC jail would be full.
- Were you able, during
the Twitter hearings,
and some of them
are still ongoing,
and now there's this TikTok
situation and all that,
were you able to find out
what level of coordination
actually took your
account out last year?
- I do have some
knowledge of that.
John Solomon has done some
really good reporting on that.
And then we had
the Twitter execs,
they came into our
oversight hearings as well.
I didn't let them talk during
my five, we get five minutes.
So I told them, I said,
"All right, you guys,
you silenced me and stole
my freedom of speech
during the entire year of
2022, during my campaign."
I said, "By the way, I won.
So you didn't, you
weren't that effective."
But I said, "So I'm silencing
you for my five minutes."
And I proceeded to
let them have it.
And I called Yoel Roth out
on his disgusting
affection for child porn.
And that it was his duty
and his job in Twitter
to take that off of Twitter,
and he did not do it.
- It was really weird, the
child porn thing with Twitter,
because nobody seemed
to care about it
until Elon Musk came over.
And then suddenly
everybody cared about it.
Elon's doing more
about it than anybody,
but now all the articles are
that he's not doing enough.
- Of course.
- But nobody cared
about it before.
But what about the people
on the government side?
Whereas I kept saying
during the hearings,
it's not that I have sympathy
for these Twitter people,
but they're private employees
who are maybe up to
no good, for sure.
But they are also working
with government people.
And it seems like we
still don't really know
who those people are or
how high that goes up.
- That is an extreme problem.
So that's in Homeland Security.
I mean, we know that
they are the ones
that run these
disinformation programs
in conjunction with the
FBI, the CIA and others.
And so this is a
serious problem.
It's a weaponization
of government
basically targeting our
First Amendment rights.
There's a weaponization
of government committee.
Jim Jordan is running
that committee.
So we coordinate on
oversight under our chairman,
Jamie Comer, and we
coordinate on these things,
but we were also-
- And do you think you
can do anything on it?
That's what everybody
always is, you know?
It's like, okay, you
have the hearing.
Does anyone pay the price?
- Yeah, so I'm a business
owner, that's really what I was,
and a mom, I've got three kids,
before I became a
member of Congress.
And I know that money
is very powerful.
So when you don't
pay for something,
that means that it discontinues.
So we've been
looking into things.
I spoke with Jonathan
Turley last night,
and he had a great suggestion
for us on oversight.
But this also goes into our
budget and appropriations.
The federal government
gives out grants.
Okay, all kinds of grants,
and that's a whole nother
topic we could talk about.
There's a lot of grants
we have to cut out.
But they give out grants
for disinformation.
So this is basically tax dollars
funding all kinds of
groups, outside groups,
and they spend all their
time, do, do, do, do, do,
finding things they
want to censor.
Then they would send them
to Homeland Security,
send them to the
FBI and so forth.
And then they come in,
and they funnel 'em down,
and then, choo,
choo, choo, choo,
wipe 'em off of
not just Twitter,
which is actually one of the
smaller social media companies,
Facebook, Instagram, on
the much bigger ones.
- Let me give you
one to look into,
because this'll blow your mind
if you didn't hear about it.
Do you know about News Guard?
Have you heard about News Guard?
- Uh-uh.
So News Guard is one of
these, you know, nonprofits,
which is funded by the
government, 750 grand.
I had Marissa Streit,
she's the CEO of PragerU,
which I'm sure
you're familiar with.
I had her on my
show talking about
how News Guard has been
looking into PragerU,
and because of that, they're
losing contracts with companies
that don't wanna work
with them anymore, right?
So then get this,
that was a Friday.
On Monday morning, I got
an email from News Guard
that they were looking into me.
I had never even
heard of them before,
but by interviewing someone
that they were looking into,
and the United States
government, 750 grand
to these people.
So that's a little.
- There's a grant.
- I normally don't give you
homework, but there you go.
- That's a grant.
- Yeah.
- They very likely have that
grant for that amount of money
or who knows, more,
and it's probably,
they have to renew it each year.
See, that is exactly what
we're gonna start looking into.
But what we have to do
is we have to take
that into the budget
and into our
appropriations process
and take a little pencil
and its eraser, and this,
we're not paying for this.
We have to cut spending anyways.
We should cut out
these programs.
And so that is what
I'm hoping to do,
and we have a lot of heavy
discussions right now
that are ongoing with the budget
while we're trying to get,
you know, senile Joe Biden
to actually come talk to us
and talk to Kevin McCarthy,
and actually start
negotiating some of this.
- Well, as long as you
went there, I mean,
what's going on
with this president?
What's going on?
It seems to me that
everyone in this town
knows something's not
right, and everyone's kinda,
you basically said
it more forwardly
than most at this point.
- And I have a great
respect for older people.
I do. I think most of us do.
But I think it's clear
and obvious to everyone
that he's definitely, I
mean, he's late in his age.
And he shows it.
His physical and mental and
speech capabilities all show it.
And that's wrong.
It's wrong of him,
it's wrong of his family to
put America in this position,
and it's an embarrassment,
but it's also dangerous
for all of us.
You know, the
Afghanistan withdrawal
is one of those perfect examples
where that was a
failed withdrawal.
And he's not the
only one to blame.
There are generals
that are to blame too.
13 soldiers dead,
many more wounded that
no one ever talks about.
Arming the Taliban,
$85 billion worth of
equipment and horrific stuff.
- That picture that
came out the other day
where they show you all
the tanks and the SUVs
and just, and the helicopters.
It's like, man, we literally
just gave them everything.
- Yeah, Bagram Air Base.
This is the one that not enough
people are talking about.
We built Bagram,
built it, used it.
We should have never gave it up.
Like, okay, withdrawal
from Afghanistan,
but we should have
kept Bagram Air Base
because of its
proximity to China,
and right there in
the Middle East.
Completely abandoned
that airbase.
And do you know who's
controlling it now?
China.
- Oh, well, of course.
- No, China.
- Wait, how, why China?
- They came in,
and they came in and
negotiated with the Taliban.
China now controls Bagram
Air Base in Afghanistan.
These are the failures that
not enough people know about.
Look at the Chinese
spy balloon incident.
Allowed it to travail
across the entire country
before they shot it down.
You know what that
is an example of?
That's an example of the type
of information and control
that China has over Joe
Biden and his family
because of the corrupt
business dealings.
On the oversight committee,
our Chairman Jamie
Comer's done a great job,
leading us into
the investigation.
We've subpoenaed the
Biden family bank records.
We have them, we literally have,
you know, they always
say follow the money?
We have followed it,
and it is proving
that they were getting
payments from China,
and let's be real.
Does Hunter Biden have
any job qualifications?
- No, of course, not.
80 grand a month
for a consulting job
and something that he had
no idea what he was doing.
On top of it, crack smoking.
- Millions of dollars.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yes.
Hallie Biden,
she's in education.
Is she qualified to be
in the energy business,
in international energy
business with China and USD?
No.
- Joe Biden himself, I mean,
50 years in government now.
I don't know that
he should be worth
millions and millions of
dollars according to the salary.
- He's been here longer
than I've been alive.
Seriously, that says it all.
And I'm not young, I'm 48.
(Dave laughs)
- Let's do, you got
two years on me.
You got two years on me.
(Marjorie laughs)
Let's do just a
couple other things.
You mentioned to me
right before we started
that you're trying to pass
the Protect Children's
Innocence Bill,
obviously connected to
all of the gender stuff
that everyone is sort of
endlessly talking about.
It's rather bizarre.
- It is.
You know, I'm a mom, so that's
the best part of my life.
And I just love our kids.
And I think childhood is such
a precious and important time.
And it's a time that we
really have to protect kids
and how they grow and develop
and how they feel
about themselves.
And there's a
sexualization happening
in our education system,
and then even worse
on social media.
And tragically we've seen a
multi-billion dollar industry
bloom practically overnight
targeting children.
So, you know, if you've
ever heard of Chloe Cole,
or maybe you've interviewed her.
- Yeah, yeah, I haven't,
but I know who she is.
Detransitioner, yeah.
- She's so brave.
Yeah, detransitioner.
And she's like a spokesperson
for the community,
which is actually really big.
Just not all of
'em wanna come out.
It's a difficult thing.
But hysterectomy at age 15,
had started a puberty blockers
at 12 or 13, testosterone.
You know, these are
the kinds of things
that these kids are doing before
they're old enough to vote,
buy cigarettes, buy alcohol,
graduate from high school,
go to college, join the
military, big adult,
get a tattoo even,
think about it.
You gotta be 18 to get a tattoo.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But they can cut
their breasts off
or horrible surgeries,
genital surgeries.
It's just wrong.
And, you know, it's
not a judgment on them.
They may be confused
or developing or have
an identity crisis.
It's not about that,
but it's about this
industry for profit
causing permanent
damage to their bodies
before they're even old
enough to be adults.
- Do you think
you'll get, I mean,
considering that
no Democrats signed
on the transparency bill,
do you think you'll
get one Democrat to,
because again, I know people
will do is they'll say,
"Well, she's either a bigot,"
or something towards
trans people,
which is actually-
- Untrue, yeah.
- Completely the reverse
of what you just said.
But that's probably why a
certain amount of Democrats
that maybe aren't
completely off the deep end
will just be like,
"I'm not signing on because
it's got Marjorie's name on it."
- And that could be the case.
They've done a really good job
creating a caricature of
me that doesn't exist,
and they present it to
the public all the time.
So that could be the case.
But I would hope
that they could put
responsibility and
rational thought
above politics and
lies in the media.
Because these are our children,
and we're seeing years later,
these kids have
serious medical issues,
and they regret it, and
they commit suicide.
You know, they say this
is to prevent suicide.
They're committing suicide
after they transition.
And it's a serious problem.
But my bill is really important.
I have a lot of support.
It's a sort of a flagship
bill for all the states.
Mine was the first bill
introduced in the nation.
What it would do is
make it a federal law
to stop any so-called
gender affirming care
on anyone under the age of 18.
No puberty blockers,
no hormone treatments.
It stops all of that.
And it gives these
victims a right to sue
if they have some sort
of injury involved,
if they've already gone
through the process.
And so I think it's important.
And I really hope that every
Republican will vote for it.
I hope that Democrats
will come around
and see this is the
right thing to do,
and we just gotta protect
kids and let 'em grow up.
- Philosophically, I'm curious,
would you prefer that it
be done at the state level?
You're obviously trying to
do it at the federal level,
but would you prefer, I mean,
obviously Cali's
not gonna do it,
but Georgia might,
Florida might.
You know, it's sort of happened,
it's actually happening
in Florida right now.
- Yeah, Georgia just did.
- Would that be your
preference generally
to have everything be
done at the state level?
- I'm a big state rights
person, but on this one, no.
I'll tell you why.
And I have this argument
with some of my
conservative friends.
They're saying, "This is
a state issue, Marjorie."
And I said, "No, it's not."
California passed the bill.
They put it on Governor
Newsom's desk, and he signed it,
making California a trans
kids' sanctuary state.
Sanctuary state.
So not only are they saying
that the government
of California is
going to wrap them in
and make this process
happen for these kids,
they also take away
parents rights to stop it.
That is a state that has
crossed the line, in my opinion.
California's not alone.
We're looking at New York,
we're looking at Washington,
we're looking at other states,
blue states that are
following down the same track
and going to enable
this process even worse.
So more children are
going to be victims.
Secondly, we do have federal
laws that prevent child abuse.
And this one, to me, falls
in the child abuse lane.
And I think it's important
to make it a federal law.
- If I'm not, I might
be mistaken about this,
but I think I saw you on
Tim Pool talking about
sort of just the division
of the states right now.
And that the red states are
really, well, they're working,
and the blue states,
it's just not working.
I've asked several
Congress people
about this in the
last couple days.
I mean, what do you
make of that generally,
and then what keeps us united
if that is the direction
that we're going in?
- Well, I've used the
term national divorce,
and my words got twisted around.
I used national
divorce for a reason,
because that's a court process.
That is a legal
process of dividing.
But I did not want
it to be mixed up
with civil war or succession,
and I'll tell you why.
When I talk about
a national divorce,
I talk about states
having more state rights,
and I talk about the
federal government
being completely shrunk down
more towards where
it should have been
and where it started out.
- Kind of like those guys.
- Yeah, they kinda knew
what they were doing.
- Those old guys,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And they warned us of a
lot of the serious problems
that we're seeing today.
I think we maintain a military.
We've gotta protect our borders.
We definitely need to stay
the United States of America.
But many Republicans,
many conservatives
have gotten so fed up
with the left's ideas.
The climate change lies.
I'm sorry, we don't wanna
give up our gas stoves.
We like to be able to buy a gas
or diesel-fueled
combustion engine vehicle.
We don't wanna be
forced onto electric.
I mean, we might
choose to buy it,
but we don't wanna be forced.
We don't want our
children being taught
that there's more
than two genders.
We say there's only two
male and female, and so on.
We could give all the examples.
And Republicans, you know,
they used to say they
needed a safe space.
The left said they
We've gotten to the
place where we're like,
we need a safe space.
And so that's what
I was talking about
when I mentioned national
divorce and dividing up.
- Is that just one of those
things that as you're saying it,
you're like, "Ugh, I know
what the media's about to do."
- Yeah, (laughs) always.
They always do it.
- Yeah.
- So.
- Do you bother
with CNN and MSNBC
and the rest of them anymore?
- I don't think MSNBC's
ever invited me on.
They just like to talk
about me every single day.
(both laugh)
CNN, I do talk with
them on the hill.
There's a lot of pretty
good reporters on the hill.
I try not to attack the media
because I actually
respect the press,
and I really want to see them.
I wanna see the political
bias drop out of the press.
And I think the profession
of journalism is a dying art.
And I really wanna see it come
back, and I want the press,
and I tell them, I
literally tell 'em this.
I'm probably one of the
few members of Congress,
if it really came down to it,
that would fight to the very
end to defend their freedom.
Because I think it's important,
and it needs to be preserved.
And I'm also, at the same time,
one of the most attacked
people by the press.
But I have a faith in humanity,
and I really wanna see
them do a better job.
And I would like to see our
press corps have their freedom
and remove the political bias
and just report the
news for the people.
- Let me ask you one more,
'cause it's sort of
happening at the moment.
Obviously there was this
horrific shooting in Tennessee.
It sounds like the
shooter was either trans
or at least identified in
some way that was non-binary
or one of these things.
We know that this is gonna call
for more pushing
of banning guns.
I mean, Biden basically
is saying it already.
Obviously you're a big
Second Amendment advocate.
Is there any, I mean,
what can we be done here?
Is there anything
that can be done
or is this just, it's
now baked into the system
that these things are
just gonna keep happening?
- I have a unique perspective.
When I was in 11th grade,
it was the first year
that then Senator Joe Biden
had gotten the law passed
to make schools
gun-free school zones.
And before that, you know,
the guys would pull
up in their trucks,
and they had their hunting
rifles in their trucks.
It wasn't uncommon for
guns to be at school.
But when I was in 11th
grade, that law passed.
Schools became
gun-free school zones.
One of the kids at my school
brought three guns to school
into the first period class
and took over our entire
school after firing a weapon.
And so we spent five
hours on lockdown.
So I know that fear of
being trapped in a school
where there's no
good guy with a gun.
The only person that has
a gun, and he had three,
was a very mentally disturbed,
emotionally upset student
that was around my same age.
And we were all at mercy of
what he might decide to do.
Luckily no one died that day.
So I have that perspective,
and I believe children are,
they're our most
precious resource.
If President Biden
is protected by guns,
Nancy Pelosi is
protected by guns,
our capital is protected
by men with guns,
I think our kids
should be protected.
And if this threat, we see
it over and over again,
if it's going to keep
going, well, you know what?
We need to harden our
schools and protect our kids
the same way we protect gold,
money in banks,
Hollywood celebrities,
their big banquets
and award ceremonies.
I believe that's
what we should do.
But I've asked this question,
I think we need to finally
take a look at SSRIs.
We need to look at
these medications
for anxiety and
depression, 'cause, I mean,
pretty much every single
one of these shooters
is on or off these meds.
I've also wondered
about this particular
shooter in Nashville.
What medications
were they taking,
if they were transitioned,
how much testosterone?
- Right, that's gonna open up
a whole other set of issues.
- Yeah, 'cause testosterone
creates aggression.
And if she's had too
much in her body,
how was that affected with
SSRIs or whatever else?
I think the American
people deserve to know.
I think the coroner's report
should be made public.
It's time to have
these discussions,
and then we need to
make decisions there.
- One more on that.
What do you think, you know,
they haven't released
the manifesto
that apparently she wrote.
I'm really 50/50 on this.
I believe in transparency.
But on another side of
that, if they release it,
it almost incentivizes
more people to do it
because then it's
saying to them,
"Oh, I can do something crazy,
and then have the whole
world read my," you know,
"Mein Kampf" in essence.
What do you think about that?
- I understand that
the thought process
of not rewarding that
shooter, but let's be real.
The shooter's dead.
Thank God for those
officers that went in.
- And which, that was
unbelievable, I mean.
- Unbelievable.
And so I believe in
the truth being told,
and we've seen
manifestos in the past.
I think this one
should be released.
It should be part of studying
what's wrong and exposing.
There also could be
a network of people.
That's something that
is being investigated
actually by law enforcement
because of this planned
Trans Day of Vengeance
here in Washington,
organized by an Antifa group.
And there were talks,
or there have been talks
of a group that raised
money for firearms training
to defend trans rights.
These are all discussions,
and maybe that manifesto
has information about this.
Again, it could be a group of
people that were organized,
and supposedly this group
called for action in Nashville.
I don't know, these are things
that are floating around.
I would hope the Department of
Justice would take it serious
the same way they're
targeting January 6th people
that walked in the Capitol.
They should be
taking this serious.
And so I do think
it should come out.
- All right, one more on a
slightly less serious note.
Do you have access to
the Jewish space laser?
- I don't, but I funded them.
I voted to fund them.
I support Israel.
- But you've never
sat in the thing?
- No, no.
(both laugh)
- Well, it's been a
pleasure chatting with you.
And I hope we can do it again.
- Nice.
Yeah, let's do it again.
- All right.
- Thank you so much.
- If you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.